[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of Harry Potter theory first things
first I just want to say a big thank you
to everyone for helping us hit 100,000
subscribers this is a massive milestone
and we really appreciate all of your
support in this video look I knew
discussing Harry Potter Lord Voldemort
the final battle of the franchise in
Avada Kedavra
now Harry and Voldemort meet on numerous
occasions and each time that they meet
they engage in a clash of magic and
seemingly every time the pair end up
choosing their signature spells to use
against the other for Voldemort
this is Avada Kedavra and for Harry its
expel yamas we see this in their
graveyard duel a Jets of green light
issued from voldemort's wand just as a
jet of red light blasted from harry's
they met in midair and suddenly Harry's
wand was vibrating as though an electric
charge was searching through it and we
also see this in their final duel at the
Battle of Hogwarts depicted in chapter
36 of the Deathly Hallows
Avada Kedavra expelliarmus the bang was
like a cannon blast and the golden
flames that erupted between them the
dead center of the circle they'd been
treading marked the point where the
spells collided Harry saw Voldemort
screen Jets meet his own spell yes I
know what you're thinking
expelliarmus worked and Harry ended up
winning due to some extraneous
circumstances but you have to wonder why
Harry would continually opt for the
disarming charm of all spells to use
against arguably the most powerful dog
Wizard of all the time there are a few
reasons that I think he kept using it
first of all areas a lot of experience
with expelliarmus he uses it all the
time it is go-to
and he is completely comfortable casting
it we never actually see how a use Avada
Kedavra and he was relatively
unsuccessful having mixed results when
casting other unforgivable curses he
used the Imperius curse successfully
while breaking into Gringotts but when
he tried to use the Cruciatus curse on
Bellatrix he had a less than favorable
result next because of his experience
with the spell he knew that it was
reliable it had work for him thus far so
why would he switch why even consider
using another spell he defeated
Voldemort in the graveyard doing the
exact same thing
next reason for Hara using expelliarmus
on Voldemort was the fact that Harry
wanted to in spite of all of the
horrible things that he had done show
Voldemort some mercy in the books we
learned that an act of great remorse may
repair a soul which has been split using
Horcruxes and harry offers Voldemort
this chance for redemption yeah it did
said Harry you're right but before you
tried to kill me
it advised you to think about what
you've done think and try for some
remorse riddle
what is this of all the things that
Harry had said to him beyond any
revelation or taunt nothing had shocked
Voldemort like this Harry saw his pupils
contract two thin slits saw the skin
around his eyes whiten it's your one
last chance said Harry it's all you've
got left
I've seen what you'll be otherwise be a
man try try for some remorse by using a
spell like expelliarmus on Voldemort
rather than a killing curse Harry was
giving Voldemort one final chance Harry
never actually kills Voldemort it was
Voldemort own curse rebounding back at
him by casting expelliarmus
Harry was giving Voldemort this one
final opportunity next Harry Potter was
just not a killer in the Prisoner of
Azkaban Harry even saved Peter Pettigrew
no Harry yelled he ran forward placing
himself in front of Pettigrew facing the
ones you can't kill him he said
breathlessly you can't black and Lupin
both Lucas Daggett will take him up to
the castle will hand him over to the
Dementors he can go to Azkaban but don't
kill him Harry gasps Betty grew and he
flung his arms around Harry's knees you
thank you it's more than I deserve thank
you
after this Harry's not exactly gracious
about Pettigrew's praise but at the end
of the day he still didn't want
Pettigrew dead
and lastly Harry just didn't want to
stoop to Voldemort's level
the killing curse was an unforgivable
curse and there's no doubt in my mind
that Harry associated it with the death
of his own parents Harry didn't feel
that killing was necessary and mad-eye
moody an author that he admired was
known to always avoid killing if
possible this is explained in the
following excerpt
I'll say this for Moody though he never
killed if he could help it always
brought people in life were possible he
was tough but he never descended to the
level of the Death Eaters Harry wanted
to become a noir himself he was very
morally righteous person he didn't need
to kill he would always avoid it he
didn't need to stoop to the level of the
other side and that's it for this video
I hope you enjoyed it as always leave
your video suggestions down below until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]